nous allons faire maintenant un tour du
côté du cinéma avec notre invité
philippe noiret et son dernier film
l'ami de vincent qui est vincent vincent
c'est jean rochefort qui est un
trompettiste qui joue dans un orchestre
de varier pas de variétés un orchestre
d'un grand music hall parisien et son
ami que je joue qui s'appelle albert et
chef d'orchestre du même orchestre
nous sommes des amis d'enfance et nous
avons fait tout une grande partie de
notre vie ensemble et au moment où le
film démarre il ya tout ce passé entre
nous sont deux amis qui ne se
connaissent pas vraiment très bien
définitive mais je crois que c'est
effectivement le fait
je crois que c'est ça un peu dans pas
mal d'amitié masculine tout au moins des
amitiés féminines je ne les connais pas
mais je sais que dans les amitiés
masculines il ya bon d amitié qui dure
près très longtemps comme ça qui sont
basées sur des souvenirs d'enfance des
expériences traversée en commun la
guerre le service militaire le sport etc
et que finalement et on peut être très
ami avec quelqu'un très intime même se
voir souvent et qu'il y ait de grandes
plages comme ça dans chacun des deux
amis qui reste inconnu à l'autre je
prends et à filter et nous allons parler
de ce film et mopar avant peut-être un
rapide extrait donc testing de pierre
granier-deferre
hélas
bonjour vous travaillez pour la coopec
willow c'est pour les soeurs steiner
elles sont toujours là vous allez avoir
du mal les bungalows e4 jusqu'au bout
container c'est l'endroit le plus humide
pouvoir 400 foot
siva by toit plus tard si bluff
philippe noiret et jean rochefort sont
aussi des amis à la ville alors comment
ça se passe à ton âge entre vous oizo
effectivement on a déjà pas mal oeuvrer
ensemble et nous sommes effectivement de
bons de bons amis à la vie ça ça ne peut
que ça ne peut que rendre les choses
encore plus agréable je dire sous la
direction de granier qui est un aussi un
un ami un homme pour qui on avait on a
tous les deux grandes estimé grande
affection
donc je ne sais pas c'est un plaisir on
se connaît bien on on a pas mal de
points communs et puis en même temps on
a pas mal travaillé ensemble donc je
crois qu'il ya un plaisir comparable à
ce que celui que va voir un peu de
musiciens qui ont l'habitude de jouer
ensemble un pianiste houérou h en terre
un accompagnateur jauzion on se connaît
on sent on aime aussi se surprendront ce
on s'attend cia il ya tout un jeu comme
ça qui est qui rend les choses très très
plaisante qu'il ferait vous êtes fait
une tête comme on dit qui accroche aux
avoirs à vingt ans vit de façonner
couasnon mois ci mais c'est parce que je
suis en train de tourner dans un film
d'alain corneau que ça pète fort saganne
qui se passe dans le sud saharien qui en
1910 et incarne un officier deux
colonels de cavalerie aux côtés de
depardieu qui n'est que lieutenant
l'uimm est jeune il a tout l'avenir
devant lui
et puis il ya aussi deux dames catherine
deneuve et sophie marceau mais enfin
c'est une tête un petit peu spécial oui
là c'est philippe noiret à bientôt
et maintenant nous revenons de
mauritanie en france pour